that's a completely
different group biggest problem right
now is black on black crime all
lives matter first of all so what about
all the people
in vermont you have signs in the
countryside in front of people's houses
yeah what's your name my name is joseph
joseph i also make money
ain't nobody fixing problems they create
and more progress
aka stretch if i can do it anybody can
let's come together people
good afternoon guys i've been abroad
for many years just came back to the
states to my home state of vermont where
i grew up until
18 years old and i was going to do a
nice little video for you
about the beauty of the state of how
it's different
than the rest of america and sort of
show it off
but with all the black lives
matter signs canvassing the state
i decided to scrap that idea and get
into the story of
why all these signs are here what's
going on with the movement
in the widest state in america
[Music]
sorry man i was just like how did you
sneak up on me
so i found a guy yesterday here david
and he said he wanted to be on camera
so let's see if he's here
david remember me we cool if we chat
unfortunately we can't ah dude really
yeah i'm not allowed to do anything
while i'm working okay okay where do you
think i should talk to people i'm gonna
go to battery park
that's the best place to go the best
place to go
okay okay so david can't talk
at work uh so we're gonna meet up later
let's go to the next location
how is it different here can i can i
make
can i shoot video i knew no no okay
yeah how is it how is it different here
than north carolina
uh here is too cold how about the people
people oh i think the same
people the same yeah we think that
the police must pay attention yeah
yeah and must uh respect the law yeah
and uh people will respect the law too
though when they don't
respect the law is not good you know
when people don't respect the law
and police don't respect allah no that's
not good even people
police everybody must respect the law do
you come from
you've come from the congo yeah you see
what happens when law falls apart right
yeah it's not good no no good
you must respect the law yeah yeah
everybody
and as you can see a bunch of tents what
we're gonna do is go talk to some of the
people in there
see what's going on i heard it's a
sit-in a protest
against the police but i also see a
black lives matter of flags
waving so let's go talk to some people
okay here we are battery park
and so battery park is the park across
the street from the police
station police station battery park sure
yeah sorry man
hello are you in charge of this this
operation
you're not you look like you are and you
got the guard dog
so i just i live abroad i just did my
quarantine
now i'm back in the country and i'm just
super interested in what's going on
why i was born in burlington oh yeah my
mom
my mom's here what's up i think you've
been away
this last in four years
[Music]
ukraine oh really yeah
so it's super interesting what do you
think about so what do you think about
the president being impeached um based
on his
um interactions and uh
uh efforts to undermine um the election
in ukraine and
he was in p what do you think about all
that stuff man
that's that's some big stuff because i
i've seen what are you an american
citizen yeah yeah i'm italian too
both dual citizen and ukrainian resident
because my wife's ukrainian
so um it's super complicated
i haven't i haven't dug deep i haven't
dug deep on that so i'll just be totally
honest i don't know
i can't say credibly um with biden's son
i do know what happened with him
working for the gas company just because
i have friends in that industry
yeah i'm not a fan of donald trump
that's for sure
he was impeached yeah by by congress i
don't think that well the impeachment
impeachment is complicated it's not like
they removed them bill clinton was
impeached too
so i think it's complicated anyways i'm
curious of the black lives matter
action and the reason why we're doing it
here in burlington
uh-huh is because it's a statement
against police brutality
okay we have three officers on the force
we feel that the state has made a big
mistake in exonerating them
okay because of their excessive use of
force and one of them
resulted in a homicide so the guy that
was killed was black
no the guy that was killed was white oh
the guy that was killed was white and he
was killed by a white officer and it was
popped in the face
and it was a fatal glove okay
okay and he was not trained in how to
de-escalate a difficult situation and he
was at the hospital emergency room
he punched a citizen in the face
who was there because his wife had come
by
andy okay so he so that wasn't a
um a white on black situation
okay but yeah
who's is there are you in charge here or
is there any is there anyone in charge
yeah yeah so i make i make videos about
different situations all over the world
i make them for myself my own channel
yeah
i look like a nazi skinhead okay they're
not really allowed here in berlin
all right but this is really comfortable
there's a little town about 30 miles
north of here
and it's called saint albans okay
there's another one about 100 miles
south of here and it's called rutland
okay and you do a hell of a lot better
down there because you'd be in good
company
but i was born here you don't have the
capacity to figure out
that donald trump is a russian asset so
you don't even belong i'm not a
i'm not a fan of donald trump but i just
feel like is your movement against
racism or for racism because you just
called me a nazi skinner
i did just call you okay and that's
because
in the short amount of time that i've
been talking to you
i'm so reversed okay then i'm gonna have
to go home and i can no longer sit up i
understand that must be hard
on the other side actually this is a
public park you don't have rights to it
unfortunately perfectly fine but you
know what i can do
what's up i'd get up and move i'm gonna
go anyways i just wanna
is there anyone i can talk to no no i
have a youtube channel
what's your name again peter santaniello
yeah on business
i can show you my channel if you want to
see
no no no i'm a registered nurse i'm just
here i'm homeless that's all so what's
your story
tell us oh yeah so like you know i'm
related to this entire thing uh you know
burma police did wrong me because i in
first i was depressed was 32 years ago
suicidal and nine years
me no no last year i tried to kill
myself nine times a gun
surprisingly it was easy to get a gun
you know i didn't need a license
you can just get guns it's like oh hey
can you tell me that sure how much ah
50 bucks cool thanks
trade i believe you know i didn't know
it was that easy
i heard every i heard there were more
guns than citizens
i mean you know i hope so because that's
it'll be a really really shitty
production if you can't even do that
right now cool let's go on a walk let's
go for a walk yes sir
i'm not i won't film you you want to
make me look good no no no no no go on
go on this side of it so i'm going to
record you want to be in it
now
okay so here's the experience in the
park
i'm recording guys i warned you i'm
recording
wow heavy heavy heavy stuff so one guy
the i think his name was kim
the nurse he was cool he wanted to talk
everyone else shut me down quite intense
i was called a neo-nazi i was called a
cop and a fed obviously because my looks
um but it wasn't really a
a loving environment let's say and i
understand when i went in there i asked
first can i record
and people weren't into that which is
fine
um but as far as having a conversation
or dialogue
there are a couple people that were cool
for the vast majority
it was quite difficult so
heavy i was actually shaking a little
bit that's the first time i felt like
that in quite some time
because it was just so uh so bizarre
anyways here's beautiful lake champlain
only way to get you away from me
is to record how come you have no no
what how can you hate talking
okay so this guy what's your name
won't stop following me around hello
and uh says i'm an agitator
so the only way to get him away
is put the camera you want to say hi
okay now that i'm digging into this
issue understanding a few things here
so uh black lives matter uh
just as a statement obviously of course
that's uh any rationally
thinking person understands this but
black lives matter
is a movement i believe it was founded
in 2013
by three women an interesting
observation is when you click on the r
co-founders page on the blm website
while it's empty
and it wasn't long ago perhaps there's a
problem with the website
perhaps not anyways you can easily
research about the co-founders to
understand their backgrounds
ideology and vision if you're either for
or against the movement
doesn't matter i strongly suggest just
going in a little deeper on the research
to understand better what you are or
aren't supporting
but then when you see a sign like this
black lives
matter showing up for racial justice.org
that's a completely different group um
with a completely different team and if
your donations go there
well they don't go to the original group
of black lives matter what do they stand
for who are they what are their
backgrounds i don't think most people
know i don't think most people dig into
that enough
and then we have that black lives matter
sign which is for a completely different
movement okay it's more complicated
than we thought all right i got five
minutes with david
what six minutes no we got four now
we started off with six all right four
minutes with david david was working
before at city what's it called
city market he's a much loved
front man everyone seems to know him man
of the community right you've been here
how long
since 1997. you like burlington
you like vermont i love romero i love it
people codia i don't have
one enemy that i can remember
39 years old about to have a baby in
november
nice and i work hard
pretty much all my life i've always
worked for mine
i got in a little bit of trouble but i
paid back my debt to society
nice how many kids you have i got three
counting this one coming in november
take a right
left all right so what's your take right
now in burlington with black life matter
black lives matter you can see on the
street here
there's a big group in the park
what are your thoughts i think all lives
matter
[Applause]
speaks speak up bro biggest problem
right now is black on black crime all
lives matter first of all and
second of all if you're living your life
and you taking care of your family and
providing
nothing else matter right this is god's
world
and we are god's children
so that's my intake on black lives
matter
okay your life matter my life matter
right
all of our lives man so what about the
movement though there's like a movement
now
you know no movement
i don't consider that a movement i just
i consider that a cry for help people
don't even know
right what type of message they sending
they're all followers so what about all
the people
in vermont you have signs in the
countryside in front of people's houses
and stuff
the program's for drug addicts right
homeless people
um that's what matters for me
and your father you raised three good
kids right i got three good kids yeah
so i do the best i can right on brother
the best of my ability anything else to
say to the world i have a big foreign
audience
you want to give them any any thoughts
to leave on
your voice can't be heard unless you
speak out
don't be afraid to speak out dude so
i live abroad i just came back to the
states
everyone seems so quiet so tense so
like they're afraid to talk like they're
afraid of being cancelled right
is that the thing
[Music]
right
[Music]
right to try to make a difference ain't
nobody
fixing problems they're creating more
problems
and the rich is getting richer and the
poor getting poorer
right i mean everything that needs to be
addressed
isn't being addressed right
and then the media just is totally
polarized doesn't give a [ __ ] about out
of control
out of control it's a story
unless it involves
making
and
you're a legend you're a legend bro
david
aka stretch stretch in the house
39 years old if i can do it anybody can
let's come together people
nice brother
[Music]
so we're getting close to the
presidential elections it's the end of
september now
once uh we have a couple months and
on this drive from burlington to virgins
about 45 minutes away
from my recollection there was always a
lot of
signs for the presidency around election
time
and the fact that there are no biden
signs
in a state that will most likely vote
fine and vermont always
votes blue it's quite odd to me
not sure why that is someone tell me in
the comments why are there no biden
signs
why are there more trump signs in
vermont than biden signs please tell me
that answer
i'm interested
all right guys here in virgins vermont
this is actually the place
i went to high school class of 95
and the goal is to find someone
with a blm sign and ask them
about the movement i've seen a few
around the town
this is a bit of a harder challenge than
i thought it would be
in the streets of virgins vermont and
in a way this is what's crazy in a way
it's harder to film videos like this
uh well talk to random people in america
then saudi arabia iran
pakistan
sensitive times sensitive issues i get
it
uh but i really think we all need a
better understanding
and i'm just learning so here we go
nobody's outside scott oxfam's house i
used to hang out with him
michael bradigan's house he used to hang
out here
and you can't really knock on a door and
with the camera rolling here
i don't get that vibe what's cool about
vermont there are many things cool about
vermont but little things like this
little details like
you know put a book in here uh take a
book
i've seen it with vegetables little
stands on the side of the road in small
towns
where people you know any extra
vegetables they have they put them there
they take whatever
so there is a very good sense of
community here in the state
which i i like i miss i appreciate now
actually i very much appreciate and i
think if you're gonna raise kids it's
probably one of the better places to do
so
and you can see here i am vermont strong
it's very nationalistic vermont it's
very proud
and i honestly think the north koreans
send delegates to vermont
to learn about nationalism because
vermont is all about
being vermont very proud of many things
which is cool in a way too because it's
it's tight
it's together do a little more walking
and then we'll we'll get to another
place one last place
that i was told to go or i can probably
meet some interesting people that have
something to say
we're in this together this journey for
those that know a lot about the movement
um well it might be interesting to see
what i've encountered
but for most most of us
i think it's a bit confusing between
um black lives matter just a statement
that i think we can all agree with
black lives matter a movement
founded by three people black lives
matter
another group that i talked about
earlier online i don't know how many of
those splinter groups
there are that are using the moniker
black lives matter
so off camera guys i've talked to a few
people
and they're not having it with the
camera
very interesting fact i live in ukraine
the former soviet union
and more people feel
[Music]
free with language there
than in the united states right now what
i think is happening
when i'm gathering if anyone talks about
this if anyone has
a conversation about the issues
then they can easily be considered
racist
and that seems to be the biggest fear in
society as if
someone's labeled as a racist person
it was the first time i've been called
the neo-nazi today that was interesting
i've been called a lot of things but
not a neo-nazi
so here we are in the last town of the
video winooski
and i was just up the street here and
then walking around
and there was a blm gathering
completely different the
woman who talked to me was super
respectful super nice
everyone seemed very calm and very cool
so i just want to make that clear that
it was a completely
different environment than when i went
to the park
uh fortunately they don't want me to
run the camera on anything no
conversations on camera
i talked for a while um they said go to
the website if you want to learn about
what we're doing here how you doing
so yeah i tried my best guys this is
just one day this is one
story there is one narration
of a very complex and uh difficult topic
it's interesting and somewhat some ways
being an outsider in my own country
coming back to the us after being gone
for so long
and trying to understand uh a very
complicated situation
and it's just you know i do a lot of
these videos in the world
and it feels very odd that
people are so tight in
in the sense that they don't want to
talk like when i was in virgins i talked
to
quite a few white people ladies didn't
want to
get on camera and so people can get
criticized or cancelled very easily
these days
but the only way forward in any of this
stuff i think is
some open discussion some conversation
and uh i've just gotten sick of all the
politicized and polarized
[ __ ] that we mainly see online and
in the media
so that's it guys i will be going
i will this is the whitest state in
america
and i will be going to the probably the
blackest place in america or one of them
the south bronx that's going to be my
next video and i'm super pumped for that
what's that buddy i'm vlogging bro you
want to be in it
yeah what do you want to say what do you
want to say subscribe to his youtube
channel
yeah buddy yeah what's your name my name
is joseph
joseph i also make my name what
bloody yeah joseph what's your youtube
channel my youtube channel is joseph
comedy
joseph comedy you're a comedian yeah
tell me a joke
you're ready road why because it doesn't
have wings
you got me man how long you been doing
it for huh
how long you been doing it for like
seven months how's it going
good cool yeah yeah
what do you have for animals in the
congo you have big gorillas in there
yeah my family
oh my god in tanzania there's some lions
all my family
they're burning in congo they're born in
the congo
how long you guys lived here uh one
american do
let's put it on the video where's your
channel joseph comedy
yeah all right man
subscribing buddy i'm ready to watch
thank you so much
they also do comedies subscribing
hey guys make sure to subscribe to this
guy all right
all right
boom brother
bye peace never give up never give up
i'm ready to see your videos you guys
good way to end it cool kids and that's
the future
thanks for coming along
[Music]
[Music]
you